i was a female ceo i had a lot of female
advisors
and i found that my male advisors that
my male investors were actually
looking out for me more than my female
advisors why is that
a competition thing and i mean you can
look at anything that women are together
it's like i need to be the alpha yeah i
want to be the top
dog you're saying women are more
competitive and catty than guys
like if i saw ruslan kill it like he had
a
made a lot of money i mean yo what up
bro that respect but i'm not hating on
the doubt but that comes with the
territory in females yeah yes very much
so why is that especially if you're
especially if you're at that higher
level they don't want you to surpass
them
and then from that point they are
demoted and now you are the star yeah
they want to be the focus
have you experienced that ali by the way
since you've kind of been killing it
making a lot of money have you seen like
women in your life obviously like the
nurse who worked with you ratted on you
and snitched on yeah i'm not talking
about i'm talking about full-on friends
have you seen friends be like
[ __ ] you now oh yeah [ __ ] like what have
you experienced with that a lot i mean i
i totally see with what you're seeing
it's it's really sad we have this huge
women's movement about coming but yet
we're not
if there's a lot of most women go at
each other and that's terrible um i've
always been in the notion like someone
else is doing well it should make you
say what are you doing well how do i do
that wow you know make you want to drive
harder but unfortunately others will try
to tear you down i think that's good
advice to our audience by the way we can
all kind of wait like there's like i
felt i remember watching i'm not gonna
say names i remember watching somebody
and and like they were doing something
really good on social media video okay
and i've been like this guy you know all
that he's kind of nervous kind of sucks
he ain't that cool and i'm like oh my
adam what are you doing you're like
hating on this dude you don't even know
because he's doing better than you
why don't you
actually actively listen and see what
he's talking about and take some nuggets
as to what they're talking about and
apply that and just improve
and just get better it's so easy to hate
yeah it's so easy to hate it's a lot
harder to congratulate right like don't
be a hater like don't drink the haterade
but that's you're saying that this kind
of comes with female nature is that what
you're saying yeah yeah and you'd think
you'd be getting better because i mean
even like on tick tock there's a lot of
uh you know even like the tone of it
seems like it's like us supporting or
like oh you know i get it i've been
there you know like they're trying to
relate but for some reason it's still
very much embedded yeah and it's a
subtle it's like subtle disses right
it's backhanded compliments it's things
that it's like oh
you know um
i would have been there or something
whatever it's
like if i got that same exposure then i
would be in the same place as you are
like
no i worked my butt off for this and
that's why i'm in this position and
you know yeah and that's a lot of and
that's female nature but that's goes
with hypergamy and all that other stuff
too you want the top you want the top of
the top
um
and yeah that's just
so what what's your ultimate advice to
women
um my ultimate advice is
get married have babies don't put them
in public schools
she's like pretty soon
i guess my question is can you do both
can you be a boss babe make your money
get that bag have a career but also be a
feminine woman
wife
mother can you do both i think it's very
difficult to do both i think that so for
me in particular i have a youtube
channel
it's you know 60 almost 64 000
subscribers
last year when i was pregnant
right before i gave birth i you know i
was working hard at it i was making
videos all the time i had to take a back
seat to my youtube channel right and
because you're the kid yeah but also
because
because
my family comes first
youtube and whatever else comes
second or third wherever it comes you
know and so what i often find is that
career focused women
don't
um
lack in the family department because
you can't do it all at you can't have it
all you can't do it all and at some
point there are things that lack right
whether that's family whether that's not
making enough money or all the money
that you want to make or you didn't hit
the milestones that you wanted to hit
all these things come
like
they all have you know a play here so
for me
i think that yes you can work you can
make good money i make good money on
youtube i mean we're not we're not
struggling okay
but at the same time if i had to walk
away today i would drop everything
and say i'm
i'm just focused on my family so your
advice is to be a mother and wife first
and then second
yeah
and i think and i think too right i'm
very entrepreneurial i'm not i'm
not stupid right and so i can help my
husband
and i and i encourage him and i give him
you know i can give my husband advice
and sometimes he does takes it sometimes
he doesn't
and
you know
it's that's that's the relationship that
we have he knows that i i'm an
intelligent person he takes he gets
advice from me on on business stuff all
the time
but at the end of the day my family
comes first my relationship comes first
my relationship with god comes first
then my husband then my child and then
everything else
by the way is that a similar
relationship you have with your wife
sounds very similar to this i would say
a lot of people have these relationships
yeah the issue is we don't preach what
we practice yeah we know what she's
describing is optimal for a human family
to flourish like we know that like hey
it's ideal to have one parent at home
hey it's ideal not to send your kids
away
to a public school for six hours a day
when it's only two hour and a half two
hours of actual work i know because my
son gets homeschooled why am i sending
him away to
a bunch of strangers to be around him
all day socialization he gets that he
plays sports yeah he's fine right so i
think if we're honest a lot of people
regardless on political affiliation or
if they're woke or liberal or whatever
would say oh yeah no that makes sense
they've done studies on i'm sure you
know adam they've done studies there uh
dual
income families net less than single
income provider families because when
you factor in the gas when you factor in
the dry cleaning when you factor in
child care eating out you take home less
money the issue is our society knows but
they don't preach what they practice and
i think that's where i think we need
more people by the way you just brought
up a very interesting point you're
saying that
if there's one breadwinner and one
let's assume that's the man without you
know feminists going crazy
uh and the woman stays at home does more
of the motherly maternal teacher you
know yes taking care rearing
and the husband can focus on work
uh
gaining resources what have you that
that family is takes home more money
nets more money versus having two cars
having more gas having to be out of the
house you got to send your kids out of
the house
very interesting data right there yep
yeah yeah and it's been like that for a
couple decades yeah but women feel the
need to get out of the house and work
too
because they don't want to be seen as
like leave it to beaver stay at home
without wear the apron and cooking all
day well that is that is the trope right
and so
feminists hate me because
i went from being a boss babe to
essentially being what they idealize
right to being
just a stay-at-home mom or just a
stay-at-home wife like look at what
she's doing she's she's feeding into the
patriarchy and all this other crap that
they like to say when in fact my
relationship is the most healthy it's
ever been right my relationship with my
family my my relationships in general
all together i'm a less abrasive person
to be around
and
to me
my life and our life
has increased
and my husband makes way more money than
i would have made
if i had continued
they surveyed mothers
who work
kids under 18. they found out that over
55 of mothers with kids under 18 would
prefer to stay at home if given the
option 55 percent and this was a pro
women's website so that's kids under 18.
imagine if they surveyed
mothers with kids under 10 who work what
percentage you think that would probably
be through the roof if given the
opportunity
most women at least 56 percent the
majority of underage so if you've got
kids under 10
under five i would i would i would
venture it's probably in the 80s or 90s
i was almost hesitant to come back to
youtube because i wanted to spend every
waking second with my daughter she's
three months old i'm like how can i take
a little bit of my time to come back to
youtube and
you know it's
it's you've you see it in the numbers
right you look at the analytics
as a content creator you're looking at
the dip in your analytics you're looking
the dip in your money you're like
youtube does a terrible job of telling
you too by the way you don't put your
dashboard up and it's like you're you
suck yeah you're trash you took a break
because you took a break yeah i took a
two i took an almost
three and a half month break or three
month break
and youtube hated me
i i went out of the algorithm and you
know how it is like you want to stay
relevant you want to stay in the know
you want to get to the numbers that you
guys see right and so
yeah it sucks but at the same time would
i trade that for my family absolutely
not so i have a question then i guess
just to play like a little double time
if um with inflation obviously and
things getting more expensive if you
were in any type of financial like where
you needed more income and your husband
was at a job where he was that's where
he gets paid like there was nothing
he was cat would you think it falls on
his responsibility to go find more money
for our household or would it be would
you feel compelled to want to help bring
in that supplement
um i would i would bring in supplemental
income but working from home yeah and
less time spent
like if a part-time job is not like
essentially youtube is my part-time job
right yeah so
i make this is our fun money and so he
makes the bill pay money and i make fun
money
and i think it's great i think women
that stay at home right the whole the
whole notion is like oh she's gonna
she's gonna get divorced and then
eventually you know she's not gonna get
anything and whatnot women learn skills
i know so many entrepreneurs that built
their businesses from their home that
raids series a series b money okay and
so they and then they say well i'm not
going to be the ceo i'm just going to be
on the board right or i'm just going to
sit the backstage because i don't want
to be at the forefront of this company i
built it to this point hand it off still
making
so much money i think the key in that is
developing skills where you can trade
results for money and not time for money
exactly because i think we're
conditioned to trade time for money and
there's a season for life
where you have to do that you're just
starting a new career
but you have to trade time for money but
i think ultimately if you're trading
results a viral video building a
business you're trading results for
money you're always going to win and i
think so many of us are conditioned to
like go to four years get the student
loan debt yeah get a career and then get
married when you're 30. and then what's
going to happen you're going to want to
have kids yeah and then what happens
well then you know so i think like the
projections on women is really hard so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]